- un mode sport avec le tour de france
le maillot jaune change d'épaulés
revient à l'estonien à carcy [ __ ] c'est
le belge tom steels qui remporte cette
deuxième étape une étape plutôt
mouvementée nathanaël de rincquesen
l'hydroglisseur voilà bien le meilleur
moyen pour voir le peloton progressé
tout au long des quatre km du bois de
noirmoutier
le bois devait marquer les esprits il va
laisser des traces
une chute collective au milieu du
peloton entraîne un embouteillage la
chaussée est étroite
104 coureurs sont pris au piège femmes
le quelques favoris joue les rinero
gothique rochard ils arriveront à saint
nazaire
avec plus de 6 minutes de retard sur ce
groupe de soixante dix échappés bien
malgré eux sur la ligne d'arrivée tom
steels s'impose juste devant jan
kirsipuu kirsi pu très habile
aujourd'hui notamment lors des sprints
bonifications a repris 30 secondes à
lance armstrong bien plus qu'il n'en
fallait pour dépasser l'américain au
classement général et au pire à
l'estonie le premier maillot jaune de
son histoire